[Music]
welcome back to curious archive this
video is the second part of a two-part
series exploring the incredible
speculative alien world of the biren so
check out part one if you haven't
already the world of the biren was first
realized by alex reese an exceptional
designer and world builder who worked on
the video game subnautica among other
things and i have links to where you can
follow and support him in this video's
description in part 1 we broke down the
biology and early history of the biren a
six-limbed sentient alien race at the
center of this fictional world but
there's still a lot to cover which is
why in this entry into the archive we'll
be chronicling the next several thousand
eons of beer in history following their
incredible arc into the far future so
let's get started when we last saw the
biren their civilization had undergone
an apocalyptic reset back to the
pre-industrial era due to an event
called the fall which turned the
equatorial region of the planet into an
inhospitable wasteland known as the kiln
this vast superheated region cut the
burn populations north and south of the
area off from one another in biren
aren't the only species on planet crier
which were affected by the cataclysmic
fall organisms like the iridali a group
of unique spear-faced predators that
thrived in the tropical oceans suffered
a disastrous population decline as their
biome and indeed the entire planet
turned upside down but even after the
fall many buren the bereft of certain
technologies continue to live relatively
average lives some populations live as
farmers of a plant-like organism called
bluestick essentially returning to
agricultural societies although the
lives of these post-fall bluestick
farmers are just a single small blip in
the vast history of the buren alex reese
has mapped out every single aspect of
the agricultural practice making his
fictional world feel all the more
palpable this diagram showcases in
detail how barron blue stick agriculture
works the blue stick grows best
alongside channels of brackish water
hence the design you see before you
interestingly the blue stick can't
photosynthesize but grows symbiotically
with a red tinted organism called raft
reed to produce energy indeed most of
the plants on planet criera are
composites here you can see the life
cycle of the strange tree within a tree
organisms that dot the landscape of
bluestick farms once again the level of
detail here is impressive the bluestick
plants are preyed upon by the glassworms
a group of small translucent pests these
creatures have evolved a specialized
hierarchy and can be divided into queens
soldiers and workers much like the
complex social structures of ants here
on earth the glassworms are in turn
preyed upon by the chattertails which
are greatly valued by beer and bluestick
farmers thanks to their natural pest
control capabilities their alarming
looking mouths are in fact folded
forelimbs used to ensnare prey when the
time is right these sharp limbs snap
forward and ensnare the unlucky
glassworms keeping the bluestick crop
safe from harm elsewhere on bluestick
farm we have the thoroughly detailed
bluestick mill a manufacturing structure
that uses a large wind turbine to power
a mortar the technology here is based on
pre-fall designs showing that buren
civilization isn't quite starting from
square one the blue stick mill grinds
the raw crops into a concentrated gel
this process blue stick is profitable
for its medicinal industrial and
chemical uses especially now that older
industries have all but collapsed
helping to farm these blue stick fields
are groups of giants the second
intelligent race on planet criera who
also suffered a population decline due
to the fall while giants and birin don't
always get along on this blue stick farm
the giants have to work together
alongside biren as you can see here with
this group taking a well-deserved
communal break from hard work and
there's something about this image in
particular which captures strangely
familiar and almost human emotions but
the pre-industrial reset wouldn't last
forever the buren technology which
supported a space-faring civilization
though forgotten and in ruins was still
out there waiting to be rediscovered
eventually global shifts in the
post-fall buren world would reach the
bluestick farms here a motorized vehicle
from an emerging global power called the
reclamation arrives to assist the
laborers and a gesture of goodwill it's
a sign that after many centuries the
world is being reborn and over the
course of the next era the rebirth
following the fall picked up speed
eventually the lethally warmed equator
could be navigated once more with the
rediscovery of powered flight here a
primitive aircraft called the kiln
runner flies high over the expanse to
avoid the searing heat crafts like this
one helped reconnect the north and south
beer populations for the first time in
over a thousand years in this next image
you can observe two byrons scaling the
first mountains one of the few places on
the planet that still possesses frigid
temperatures these explorers are another
sign that long after the fall the world
is finally starting to reconnect one
detail i especially like is their unique
suits come with mouth-operated
multi-tools which makes sense since the
burren often use their beaks as well as
their front limbs when manipulating
objects in another scene showing the
burren society making impressive strides
towards a more technologically advanced
civilization here a reclamation heavy
lift delivers a wind turbine to the
buren of a river valley this image shows
that long forgotten technology is
spreading across the planet once more
and the distant populations are
reconnecting with each other like any
movement however the so-called
reclamation is complicated many parts of
the faction are more interested in
empire building than helping to rebuild
homes indeed one thing i like about the
buren world is that its history isn't a
straight line but a long road of
progress and backsliding with the
mistakes of the first beer and
civilizations still in many minds
however overall the byron species would
begin to move towards a better tomorrow
here you can see a twin-mast reclamation
ship hosting along the edge of the
tuktali region marveling at the ruins
along the coastline which have not been
seen for thousands of years since the
tuktali region is located deep within
the kiln it would have been inhospitable
for quite some time but now it like many
other cities are being rediscovered by
now byron society is at last entering a
second age of scientific advancement
soon more egalitarian reclamation
efforts would emerge on both sides of
the kiln here a burren plane-like
vehicle called the cresting wave begins
to make its ascent in front of a
sustainable gleaming city showing that
the gloom of the fall is truly lifting
even more striking in this image you can
see the buren rediscover rocket
technology through reverse engineering
ancient pre-fall designs these rockets
aren't as effective as the old ones but
advancements would continue throughout
the next several centuries as burn
technology ultimately advanced even
beyond that of their predecessors here
at an even later date we can see the
space program has expanded as a buren
astronaut explores a nearby planet as
part of the species first program to
chart the further reaches of the buren
solar system considering all the
suffering that the buren society endured
it's a stirring image of all they've
overcome
eventually it's possible that the buren
would even encounter some future version
of humanity this image is no longer
officially canon according to alex reese
but it shows an intriguing possible
future where technologically advanced
humans in birin study interactions
between babies of both species to gather
data for a hypothetical joint colony
personally i find this alternate future
really intriguing but perhaps if the
buren ever encounter humanity it won't
be humanity as we know it in this final
famous image from an unknown point in
the biren's future we see two byron
meeting an awe-inspiring visitor simply
called the metahuman is this powerful
being an artificial descendant of
humanity several millennia into the
future at a time where our technology
has turned us into something we scarcely
would recognize that's certainly my
theory although it's left up to the
viewer's interpretation in the end it's
an enigmatic image purposefully left
vague a story which has yet to be told
the biren are both a cautionary tale and
an uplifting one the story of a
civilization that rose and fell and rose
again if you liked this exploration into
their society i'd encourage you to check
out more of the biryan on alex reese's
own page as there are extra details on
his site including his creative process
behind some of these excellent images
once again links are in the description
like i said in part 1 alex reese is also
planning to release a book on this
incredible world sometime in the future
so stay tuned for that also thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this entry
please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you